and damian you know talking to anna
there and she's had a dreadful
experience she's she's been traveling
for two days uh why is it when she gets
to a country like here like poland she's
been waved through without any
really significant visa checks but will
she come to the uk it wouldn't be the
same case
well look first of all all of our hearts
go out to
these families mothers children who have
had these extraordinary difficult
journeys in the most horrible
circumstances and look our country is
absolutely stepping up to the plate as
other
friends and neighbors across europe are
doing to make sure that in this time of
their greatest need we are there for the
for the ukrainian people and we've as as
you know jen we've we're creating two
big new routes
uh to to enable um uh people fleeing
from the from the conflict in in ukraine
to be to be welcomed in our country and
support it and that is absolutely the
right thing to do
but they still have to go through the
visa processing don't they and there are
you know countries like france i'm just
wondering
what concerns we have that countries
like ireland and france don't have
so well we're putting in place uh an
absolutely expedited process to do that
we've got
um application centers um being set up i
mean close to where
close to where people are rather than
having to to go necessarily um elsewhere
we're staffing up our applications that
is right across europe because of course
once people
people from ukraine have schengen rights
to move into a country like poland or
the other
or or some of the other uh nearby
country then they can also move um
through the schengen area just a matter
of course that's not to do with the
current conflict but just anyway
so so they may come to application
centers elsewhere we want to make sure
that we have the warmest most supportive
welcome possible and so things like this
the extended family program which we
have
which um
for which
hundreds of thousands of people a couple
of hundred thousand uh is the estimate
uh it may be eligible for but also
there's community sponsorship routes
where um local groups organizations
churches local authorities individuals
can can support an
an individual a family coming from
ukraine it could be somebody they know
but it may be that they don't of course
know anybody
uh in the country and then we can match
them up um this will be up and running
in a few weeks time can match them up to
somebody who needs that support to make
sure we're absolutely maximizing what
we're able to do
why is it taking a few weeks
no it's not just to be clear it's not
so the the the existing family in a few
weeks time
that's that's one particular there's one
particular aspect
i think family system is is up and
running now the extended family system
is going to be is tomorrow
and then yeah if you could to create a
system to match up
people from in from in country with uh
with families and local community
organizations here that will take a bit
longer for that matching system but we
do already have of course
a resettlement community and support
program that's operated for example to
welcome people from from
the syrian conflict in the past so we'll
be able to do that we'll be able to do
that quickly there is absolutely no uh
intention of any kind of delay here
people need help now um we're conscious
there are very large numbers of people
in poland and romania and elsewhere we
also are giving support to
to the region that's very important as
well to our friends for example in
poland to make sure there is
humanitarian assistance but we do
recognize of course
that people need that and they need to
be able to to get away poland and others
can't deal with it all on their own
absolutely not we are there and the
other countries in europe are there to
make sure the support is in place
for those for those families who've been
to this most appalling time
so do you know how many visa
applications have been submitted and
been processed since last wednesday
so um so far a
relatively small number i can't give any
i can't give an exact number a
relatively smaller but we expect that to
grow rapidly so we are we're stepping up
the capacity we're putting in place now
we're very soon up to
capacity for 6 000 a week but we'll keep
it under review and if it needs to
increase it will increase that sorry
that's just in the immediate region
there's also course application centers
across europe and as i say because of um
in the schengen area because people will
be able to move and some will we also
expect there to be applications made in
some of those other centers as well so
we will absolutely make sure but you
must know roughly how many you ukrainian
people have granted visas in the last
week i mean i know you can't give me an
exact figure but but are we talking a
handful are we talking a few hundred
look it's happening it's happening all
the time and changing all the time we'll
be growing all the time but what i'm
telling you is what i can tell you is
like the number of appointments that
are available in a normal
normal circumstance 890 appointments are
available in a week in that region we
are growing that
uh already it's been to three thousand
it's gonna assume yet six thousand so
that gives you an order of magnitude
kind of week by week but that's just in
the immediate region there can be
applications further afield as well and
most importantly jennifer may
we will keep reviewing that so we make
sure that the capacity is there so we're
not keeping people waiting unnecessarily
we can progress with this quickly and
help people to to to to get on in their
lives bearing in mind that it's still
going to be hugely difficult
circumstances of course when they do
arrive in our country and that's why
things like the family support links and
these
community sponsorship programs are are
really really valuable because they help
people to
um you know to to make sure that
children can you know are well settled
in education to to be looking for
uh
for work or to navigate the benefit
system all of these things are
an important part of the overall world
they are but but it does seem to me that
that you know we're talking now about
the biggest movement of people this
century across europe and there are
hundreds of thousands pouring into all
of these countries and it from what
you're saying uh the uk haven't yet
processed more than a few hundred
it's it's as complex for poland and
romania and all of these other countries
isn't it as it is for the uk
yeah so
so these two new programs are just
starting as i say the
extended family uh programmes will start
from from tomorrow and the community
resettlement um sponsorship program that
that will take a a wee while longer for
good reason because you've got to set
these things up in play up
correctly and make sure the safeguarding
is there and and so on to make sure it
works for what works for everybody
and but my commitment is absolutely that
we will make sure we can
uh we we can work through the people who
want to fight this country and this is a
it is a it is a big offer i mean you
talk about hundreds of thousands there
are hundreds of thousands
of people will be eligible for these um
for just you know for this extended
family program and the new community
sponsorship program it is a big it is a
big volume off and rightly so in these
circumstances when all of us
all of us around
the world have to and and are pulling
together to make sure we are there to
stand with ukraine in this
hardest possible set of circumstances
that people find themselves in these
terrible
traumas that you know children are going
through separated from separated from a
parent and so on to make sure that we
can make that process as at least as
smooth as as it can be in these
circumstances
we've just had a bit of breaking news
some reports that there's been a big
u-turn at the international paralympic
committee uh saying yesterday that the
russian and belarusian athletes could
compete but not under the national flag
now saying
that they aren't going to compete we
haven't been able to confirm that as yet
but what would your reaction be if that
was the case
well as you say that clearly is breaking
news because you've just broken it to me
i didn't know that if that is true
i i would welcome that
i've made the decision that the the
committee made
i know these are difficult circumstances
but i think it is incredibly important
the strongest possible message the
committee thought for having set in pla
put in place the strongest possible
measures i don't think that was the
strongest possible set of measures what
you've just described is the strongest
possible set of measures and so if that
is true
um i i welcome that
let's just briefly before we leave you i
come back to the situation on the ground
in ukraine um when you look at what we
think has happened in kirsan um and and
what is happening in places like mario
paul um russia seems to have this policy
now of trying to cut off
towns and villagers and almost starve
the people out do you think
that this is what russia is trying to do
and if so how concerned are you about
this tactic
look at how concerned i'm at we're all
desperately concerned i mean this is a
ruthless
invading force
um i mean when it comes to
tactics and military strategy
i'm i'm not gonna
second guess what vladimir putin what he
might be thinking what might be in his
head but we do know
that this is a this is a ruthless a
ruthless force um and extremely i mean
obviously imminently right now for
ukraine but actually dangerous for the
wider region for europe and and the
world
and that's why it's so important and i
mean the bravery the tenacity that we've
seen from
from the people of ukraine my god we
have all been we have all been taken
aback and it is so important that we do
do everything we can
to uh to support them in in what they're
doing and to make sure and this is where
all the sanctions and uh and you know
we've got the economic crime bill
transparency and enforcement coming
through on monday in parliament's why
all these things are so important to
make sure that we absolutely make
make the regime
okay damian hines thank you very much
and thank you very much for joining us
this morning on sky news